boa noite eu não conto com 481 pessoas
no maracanã não conseguiram votar nos 11
12 no maracanãzinho porque nós
conseguimos mas enfim eu queria falar
uma experiência recente falar um pouco
de gente lá eu trabalho em uma indústria
onde eu não vendo nenhum produto não
preste um serviço que eu faço é montar
time escolher pessoas extrair delas
menores de andar quando deixei a seleção
me deixaram exatamente como foi a do
sentido da do meu afastamento minha
saída mas a eu voltei pra universidade
uma idéia é capacitar e voltar pra botar
o mercado de alguma forma mais preparado
e se informar na puc do rio há muitos
anos atrás em economia vai voltar eu fui
ao sprint são paulo é porque aqui no rio
é uma matéria da final a palestra que
convidavam para dar aula de
empreendedorismo empreendedorismo tenho
como vamos empreendimentos eu acredito
em pessoas e tal eu invisto com alguns
riscos maría e comecei a fazer isso
amanhã e que comecei em treino um
professor mário de uma liderança
empreendedora noções de liderança para
jovens empreendedores é muito bom em
tecnologia aqui mas tem dificuldade em
lidar com pessoas comunicação quem são
bons a quem digitar mas são muitas vezes
têm dificuldades em falar em público nem
em criar time sem cobrar e receber
feedback há poucas semanas atrás de uma
dinâmica na aula na turma entrou
segunda-feira digitais a aulas lá nessa
dinâmica falei no final o seguinte vocês
eu sou o presidente uma grande
corporação e você consegue vender pra
mim eu quero trabalhar comigo é que se
faz um pit de um minuto você tem de
forte realmente o ponto forte seu ponto
fraco
quem ia melhorar se segue não tem pontos
fracos estão mentindo não se ter a
consciência de que o número real que é
grave
e aí ponto forte que foram várias formas
100% os jovens foram de duas coisas só
duas coisas pareciam seus pontos fracos
primeiro toda disciplina são criativos
toma conta em processo disciplinar o que
repetiria
eles já tenham um segundo nem deu mal
com frustrações qualquer 'não não não'
hoje em dia não desiste eu saio muito
negro rapidamente eles fazem portanto da
perseverança é importante a gente tem
que ir pensando que ferramenta
interessante que a gente quase não usa o
esporte
o esporte você tem que ser disciplinado
para ter algum tipo de êxito ponta
disciplina e medição disciplina
motivação falou gobbi motivação
disciplina e uma ferida com oscilações
permanentemente você perde você ganha
você cortado da seleção você coloca no
banco você não é instalado você é são
ilustrações frente a segunda vitória
estes frustrações e voltar no dia
seguinte melhorar e aprender
eu sempre digo isso quando você aprende
você nunca perde aquela missão de
conclusão deve fazer o que você deve
fazer diferente para não sentir aquele
sentimento de novo toque permitem o
esporte é uma ferramenta importante que
eu não a um projeto nacional há coisas
aqui e ali e começar um pouquinho da
missão eo jovem quando eu ponho a nossa
missão na história ea itaú admissão eu
me refiro a uma instituição chamada os
all blacks íntegra da nova zelândia é
muito mais do que o futebol no brasil
nova zelândia álbuns que remete à origem
da nação não é o hacker toque na mente
das origens e raízes de uma nação diria
um jovem se tornar um albergue a maior
honraria que um time jovem neozelandês
pode obter permissão dele recebe aquela
camisa e se torna parte daquele grande
projeto nacional
quando teixeira que ela também alguns
anos depois de muitos anos depois de
deixar a camisa 1 ponto superior ao que
ele encontrou se ele agregar valor somar
contribuir com o projeto essa missão
dele e aí eu tive uma experiência muito
interessante essa falta do dia 21 de
agosto de 2010 a sair dia da final
olímpica aqui no rio de janeiro contra a
itália
serginho você acha que eu tinha era um
livro do time joga de azul seria uma
mancha amarela que o time jogava de
amanhã quando termina aquela partida com
40 anos chega no vestiário tira a camisa
dele sem conhecer a história dos all
blacks e fala ele me chamou de padrão de
jogo à seleção em 2001 ele menino de uma
origem muito humilde periferia de são
paulo
segundo um líder pelo exemplo nenhum
esporte transformou a vida dele da
família dele
ele é o patrão tinha para repetir na
seleção ele já o patrão os bancos na
hora de chat onde estava a cargo de joão
grandão chamado de professor mas todos
me chamavam de psicopata porque a eu
tenho de cabeceira de ônibus para a
noite no bairro ou seja aqueles caras
têm quase uma paranóica para amanhã em
fazer em realizar e não desistirem
melhorar e crescer essa coisa da
excelência e amd opteron
chame a camisa com vocês um dos tempos
do voleibol brasileiro potencial de
geração de prata maracanãzinho um pouco
palco disso tudo toda achando que você é
minha cabeça passa quiserem o chão por
um museu total 16 anos depois de ter
ingressado na seleção comigo nenhum e
deixava a camisa dele um ponto muito
superior à que tinha encontrado ele
havia cumprido a missão dele contribuído
para um projeto de fazer do voleibol
realmente uma referência mundial em uma
empresa vitoriosa falar um pouquinho uma
empresa
eu acredito nisso um processo permanente
de crescimento
eu digo aos jovens qual é um processo de
lã em outra sempre oni aprender a
aprender com esse pequeno que assim
mesmo essa quase obsessão evolução
quando você chega lá há outras para
jogar no inter são paulo vou te dizer o
seguinte meu erro foi quando cheguei lá
e fiz um programa de futebol americano
universidade americana vitorioso eu
pensava eu tenho que me manter lá não
tem que manter o tempo continuar a
crescer e se mais é de crescimento de
novas realizações e tem permanecer
conosco e é um processo permanente quer
contar um pouquinho atrás de uma
história que eu cheguei à seleção em
2001 do feminino que acontece há 16 anos
e não tenho tempo pra falar dos 24
seleções
eu cheguei me deparo com um momento de
muito talento no nascimento de um
talento mas uma empresa que é a sexta
colocada no ranking mundial
eu queria que iria chegar ao topo
disciplina tal receber pelas questões
disciplina primeira disciplina
disciplina ponte nossos sonhos nossas
realizações eu tenho um projeto e
planeja como é que eu vou chegar lá se
não cumpre aquilo dia a dia vou chegar
lá disciplina que tem áreas de
excelência quer dizer não o que você
gosta e se está a fazer aquilo que você
quer fazer uma homenagem pela equipa não
parece motivação é que todos os dias
acordamos motivado 100% motivado para
fazer aquilo que devemos fazer mas se
como disciplinado nós faremos
aquele dia que você acorda mais cansada
do programa fazer exercício físico é
chegar lá e bati num anúncio do
governador foi um soneca lá mas se você
fosse nada você vai fazer você não faz
fica meio frustrado
a disciplina tv com isso em risco coisas
que hoje mora inimigo do crescimento é
como se as invasões de conforto o
desconforto ele provoca essa busca por
uma coisa melhor e tawil muito raro que
um treinador que me transformei num
provedor de zona de desconforto
estou ansiosa como ganhar de caras não
tinha nenhum título mundial a itália
tinha 31 passar esses caras
a idéia é essa quem era realmente marca
da sua massa todos eles ainda que o
somatório realmente fosse maior e nós
chegamos lá escolher pessoas
eu brinco dizendo que eu sou o maior
estudioso de tom brady no brasil esse
cara se tornou o maior campeão da
história do pan americano e as jogadas
era evidente no entanto esse cara é o
cara se eu discutir os verdadeiros
celular mas é interessante ver um cartaz
com quem fala de como é que o escolhido
de couro de pessoas porque nós
escolhemos pessoas elas fazem a coisa
acontece gente como é que se dá a
escolha de universitários que tornam
profissionais universitários
profissionais no draft que o dia da
escolha de loteria de na sete rodadas
onde 200 e tantos 300 jovens corrida
normalmente ele foi escolhido o número
quase não foi escolhido como é possível
que uma indústria de 9 bilhões de
dólares sem noção de quanto vale o
principal time mais valioso das chaves
está na final nos estados unidos vale 5
bilhões de dólares que é o dallas
cowboys
a última estimativa em relação a nenhum
efeito que eu tinha dele 3.6 milhões de
dólares como é que em 2009
tantos milhões cometeu erro tão
grosseiro de não escolher entre o totem
pelo menos esse cara é a melhor
explicação ela vem de um rival de tom
brady não de um parceiro dele um cara
que nunca jogou com ele mas sempre
contra ele me tirou um bombeiro de fora
para dentro conteúdo rápido rápido e
muito forte não é forte nem tão preciso
que serão demitidos de dentro pra fora
com o tamanho do coração daquele cara
quando ele está disposto a dar pelo seu
time
segundo esse rival ninguém estaria
disposto a dar se preparar mais para
atingir as ou se o objetivo do que tom
brady e essa é a razão pela qual
escolher as pessoas certas
agora quando falo de pessoas liderança
falou a base disso tudo é a primeira a
integridade transparência
vamos é muito talentosa mas se você
desconfiar um pouco do processo muitas
coisas acontecem
atenção porque o líder não quero fazer
que é conveniente mas o que é certo é
certo nem sempre é simples nem sempre é
popular mas aquilo que tem que ser feito
saiba chineque para o primeiro ciclo nós
quatro anos nós chegamos lá em 2003 dois
anos depois de consumir
nós atingimos a liderança do ranking
mundial
de onde nunca saiu no domingo 19
perdemos hoje para a sérvia turquia
chateado não estava lá mas continua
ligado
eu tenho estado de permanente que é
preocupado muito preocupado preocupada
sempre preocupado
então já mandei nessa área tocando mais
eficiente
chegamos lá 2004 dia 29 de agosto temos
o ouro em atenas e concluímos nosso
primeiro ciclo
chegamos lá é mais difícil chegar ao se
manter lá que as armadilhas que você se
colocar cegos começam em fados para
conhecer os caras e tal e mais do que
nunca a gente estava realmente seguir
essa é a foto de quatro anos depois para
dilma parece mais a foto de um funeral
de um parente próximo da equipe que
trata a foto de uma prata olímpica
porque o resultado do passado não
garantem nada no futuro não sei
expectativa de responsabilidade
celso neto do antigo rock in rio só
garante uma coisa os organizadores que é
vamos fazer ainda melhor pois conquistar
um novo ouro
caso contrário os decepcionaremos como é
que a gente faz isso melhor primeiro
liderança lideranças que inspiram na tv
meta com consistência com o seu time
fazendo a coisa certa e evitando que o
grande inimigo da condição que tinha que
seu ego e vaidade fora de controle se
instaure naquela zona tinha a frase que
ela pintar eu posso até ganhar uma
partida mas jamais ganhei um campeonato
você precisa de um time um dia mas eu
acredito em time e tocar a cia
um dia decidiu não mais do que tinha
tido uma atuação um pouco egoísta pouco
selfish tal já não tinha passado muito a
bola e tal e disseram-me que eu lembre
se que na prova assim não existe letra
haidê eu e ele então respondeu mas
lentes a provar o erro existe ae
ou seja o talento é importante mas que o
talento realmente ele faça o time
produza mais e faça a coisa realmente
acontecido eu participo de alguns
conselhos ea concelhos onde a palavra
àqueles mais dizem observar muito a
postura das pessoas pode nós nós nós há
um outro conselho que nós temos com sua
empresa sofrendo onde o eu eu eu olho e
eu tenho que vir um pouquinho decidiu
chamar o ego o seu inimigo problema que
não lembro
portanto continuou sofrendo aquela
empresa onde as agendas são pessoais e
não do coletivo
quatro anos depois eu descobri que
tinham a palavra quase é não eu quase
bati a meta não bate
quando entreguei eu não entreguei o ator
depois nós quase ganhamos o olho de novo
mas ficamos no quase 2 a 0 para nós 21
19 no terceiro set e nós perdemos na
rússia lembrando disso vale lembrar que
esquece que eu sou o problema então dá
pra lembrar disso
o fato é que nós perdemos como é que se
aprende com as derrotas com um percalço
não conseguimos entregar como é que se
aprende primeiro assumindo
responsabilidade
se continuarmos atribuir a outros
responsáveis são nossas do tipo não mas
o juiz não o governo taxou e coxim não a
china não cresceu desculpa nós temos
alguma parcela de responsabilidade
e se não assumir nossas
responsabilidades nunca vamos entender
as verdadeiras razões pelas quais
perdemos na proteção de um bem a matéria
prisão foi bem desculpa alguma nós temos
assumo a responsabilidade
aprender com os próprios erros gente que
aprender com os outros é muito bom
podermos nos mas não vamos errar e temos
que aprender
o ideal seria prender alguns o ano vai
acontecer faça aquilo que é certo e não
aquilo que é conveniente espera que está
na minha cabeça a cabeça permanentemente
e seja residente
essa questão se resistente porque nós
perdemos a quatro pontos de um ouro
quase demitido obviamente uma prata
olímpica no brasil é algo por voleibol
complicado e tal mas nós vamos resistir
aqui como resistir aquela frustração
gigante e continuamos trabalhando
criando fazendo e pergunta muitas vezes
e foi o grande pulmão é o maior da
decisão mais difícil que tive que tomar
as pessoas imaginam que acompanhou levou
algum tempo porque houve realmente um
corte que tive que fazer e as pessoas
diziam naquele momento eu suportei um
grande jogador ricardinho
as pessoas começaram a me questionar não
botou o filho dele nepotismo
edinho não esse cara não dá vocês acham
que espera ter uma atitude tão como a
imprensa quis fazer e não é injusta e
incorreta em corrente parcial
o restante tem que ter continuado no
tempo nem por tantos anos eu me aceito
como ilha outra me falar na condição de
vida e quando eu comunico corte e
perguntou o que falar alguma coisa e
alguém levanta a mãe fala patrão para o
lançamento em excesso de dinheiro você
não tinha feito nada estaria p da vida
com você que já esperavam que eu fizesse
alguma coisa que estava vendo pra
inscrição de valores
isso não é uma avaliação de caráter
nossos valores são time da unidade time
trabalho extremo treinamentos e não quer
fazer parte de um
quem não quer trabalhar com dedicação
tem em intensidade não serve para o
nosso time
portanto tive que fazer aquilo que era
difícil era o dilema cultura nossos
valores e desempenho ele entregava
mandava desde a nossa cultura e tomei a
decisão de privilegiar o time ea cultura
para que a gente pudesse subsistir a
batalha seguinte 16 anos depois eu
cheguei à seguinte conclusão que o
vencedor apenas um bandido que tentou
mais uma vez não desistiu e seguiu em
frente
tentou de novo assumir responsabilidades
aprendeu uma lição muito interessante de
um homem chamado macri foi comandantes
lei dos cios que a décima edição de
makroyan que diz o seguinte se a lista
nacional negativa é tão difícil tornar o
negócio é um processo complicado 150
jovens se alistam 30 e poucos concluiu
em curso praticamente 130 existem se
tornar nem vizinhos como é que se dá
essa desistência a 1 se no parque
central jovem vai bater três vezes este
ano ele então desistiu do negócio
nós quem é que nunca pensou em desistir
em algum momento pensamos em desistir
não vai dar não conseguir
nós vamos encontrar sido a nossa
caminhada ea mensagem é nunca toque
ensino se tocarem ensino vão se
arrepender porque a gente usa muito o
pensamento de que a dor é temporária ao
mundo sofreram mas o orgulho de não ter
desistido de tentar total que era pra
sempre
nós tentamos fazer e não podia existir
naquele momento havia perdido os
partidos a fazer um jogo mais tensa me
perguntava o jogo mais tenso da sua
carreira tem que fazer um esforço na
área sou um cara tranquilo não lembro
aos tensos mas enfim o jogo contra a
frança em 2006 mas ele perdeu duas
partidas nossa atenção a frança também
pertence àquela partida na fase de
classificação o traria para casa em um
lugar só tinha perdido aquela partida
voltava para casa em um lugar não
estaria falando com vocês aqui hoje
estaria de pé do corcovado também eu né
aqui jaz bernardinho quem me trouxe
ficar no lugar no rio de janeiro uma
seleção com tanta expectativas positivas
não ia dar certo mas o fato é que aquela
partida mas vencemos e seguimos em
frente
e aquele tormento decidir onde nós não
tocamos o cine fomos um time antes de
qualquer coisa e talvez com a geração
menos talentosa em comparação ao
primeiro é uma boa geração mas não se
comparem talento o primeiro
essa foi mais resiliente a mais
resiliente criticada duvidada e não
venceu porque tinha mais talento que ela
venceu porque a determinação treinamento
extremo e um propósito eles vão provar
que era um digno representante do sport
vitorioso e conseguiram na situação mais
extrema que a jogar em casa sob pressão
um todo em preto e se limitam e
realmente foi o momento mais difícil que
eles souberam resistir a isso disse uma
coisa valores cultura a propósito mas
lembre se que o líder é o guardião de
valores
certamente a empresa mas temos valores
da empresa muitas vezes lá as poucas
vezes no lugar em casa não vamos botar
na porta de casa os valores de nós temos
filhos adolescentes
negociamos permanentemente eu tenho uma
filha de 17 anos amigo de alguns dos
nossos alunos que estão aqui negociar
muito com ela dizendo direito agora
melhorarem a base da negociação que está
perdendo sempre mas vou tentar negociar
que negocia nessas horas podem voltar
àquela onde elas podem ir lá e álcool
mas não negociamos integridade e
respeito isso não se negocia
são os valores o líder é o guardião dos
valores que a gente possa ter realmente
a cultura força do nosso nas empresas da
nossa terra o projeto da nossa estrutura
eu queria deixar passar um vídeo de um
pouquinho da importância do esporte
[Música]
estava realmente relativamente tranqüilo
da bandeira começa a subir
ou seja e aí eles começam a derreter um
pouco só um pouco e aí
em dois lances finais e agora o último
ponto que a de informação nesse ponto eu
voltei pra explicar pra gostar um pouco
nós fazemos eles partem antes de
terminar
contra todos os prognósticos a geração
que era tida como a rodada não como um
valor de um campeão olímpico ela
consegue um dos prognósticos em desistir
sendo residentes em um time mais do que
nunca vencer a competição mais difícil
que nós podemos enfrentar que deixem de
se estar lá torcendo muito por nós e eu
agradeço obrigado a fazer
[Aplausos]